bonjour à tous alors pour ceux et celles
qui ne me connaissent pas je m'appelle
charlie danger et je suis vulgarisatrice
scientifique
alors c'est pas un gros mot métier ça
veut juste dire que c'est de vulgariser
la science c'est à dire de rendre la
science ludig ludique et accessible au
plus grand nombre et je le fais
notamment sur ma chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle les revues du monde et qui est
une gêne qui parlent principalement
d'histoire et d'archéologie et comme
beaucoup de personnes
j'ai des déformations professionnelles
et une de mes des formations
professionnelles à moi c'est que j'ai
tendance à chercher la logique et la
science derrière des comportements de
mon quotidien complètement lambda par
exemple le jour j'étais dans mon lit
c'est un matin et je me réveille en
douceur et j'ai décidé d'aller sur
instagram et donc je commence à aller
sur l'application et je scroll etc
et je tombe sur le profil d'une jeune
femme que je trouve extrêmement jolie et
là je passe la demi heure suivante à
regarder quasiment toutes ses photos en
particulier s'est alloué les tue et je
me rappelle très précisément de ce
moment parce que je ressentais comme un
comme un espèce de mal être un petit peu
comme si j'avais une une voix hyper
inconsciente dans ma tête qui me disait
waouh regarde elle est quand même
vachement mieux que toi
et là ça va super surprise parce que
déjà plusieurs raisons moi je suis
quelqu'un qui a relativement confiance
en soi je veux dire j'ai a priori aucun
problème avec moi même et je me compare
très difficilement aux autres également
la jeune fille en question elle était
très chouette mais c'était pas du tout
le genre de contenu que je moi j'ai
l'habitude de consommer sur instagram
est parlé de fitness ouakam ans j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] des transcender voilà
c'était pas le genre de choses que moi
j'aime et à côté ça et bien il y avait
ce sentiment de malaise que je
ressentais qui étaient là et malgré tous
ces éléments je venais de passer 30
minutes sur le profil de la jeune fille
a regardé toutes ces photos et là je me
suis demandé pourquoi pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on suit
des gens soient des réseaux alors que ça
nous fait pas du bien et surtout
pourquoi est ce que ça nous fait pas du
bien pourquoi est-ce qu'en voyant le
profit
de cette jeune femme très jolie au
demeurant j'ai spontanément presque
instinctivement eu le besoin de me
comparer à elle et comme c'est mon
métier et que j'aime chercher un petit
peu la petite bête derrière mais
comportement et mes vielles à moi et
bien du coup j'ai décidé de mener la
petite enquête et ce que j'ai fait c'est
que j'ai commencé par observer les neuf
profil instagram des modèles les plus
suivis en france et j'ai pas regardé
leurs profils en particulier j'ai plutôt
regarder leurs abonnés et une choses
hyper surprenante que j'ai constaté
c'est que ces jeunes femmes extrêmement
jolie elle n'était pas suivie comme on
pourrait s'y attendre par une majorité
d'hommes
mais elle était suivie par une majorité
de femmes et en même temps je me suis
rappelé d'une étude qui date de 2008 de
2018 et qui est de la rsp h et qui
démontrait très clairement que instagram
augmentait les risques de dépression
chez les femmes en même temps que ça
diminue et notre estime de nous-mêmes et
notre confiance en nous
en anglais il existe même un terme pour
ça ça s'appelle le clipping et c'est un
terme qui vise à désigner justement
cette tendance qu'ont les femmes à se
suivre les yeux entre les autres non pas
parce que ça précise spécialement leur
contenu mais plutôt dans une forme de de
rivalité féminine soit pas ce qu'on
recherche
un modèle à égaler soit parce que au
contraire on va plutôt à avoir tendance
à jauger la concurrence est alors quand
je parle de rivalité féminine
je parle pas d'une compétition qui
serait basée sur la force
en vérité il s'agit plutôt d'une forme
de de peur vraiment inconsciente
intériorisé qu'on aurait d'être
supplantés par une autre femme soit dans
le domaine professionnel soit dans le
domaine personnel en vérité on devrait
même pas parler de rivalité féminine
parce que ça fait un peu cp on devrait
plutôt parler de compétition intra
sexuelle alors c'est pas non plus un
gros mot
c'est un terme qui a été apportée par
charles darwin dans les années 1850 et
qui vise à expliquer justement cette
tendance va avoir un sexe justement au
sein d'un même sexe à se mettre en
compétition pour justement excuse-moi
obtenir des droits en matière de
reproduction
donc en essayant justement de chercher à
plaire à l'autre sexe
et cette tendance à l a été énormément
observé chez les hommes on l'a
énormément étudier on sait que les
hommes ils ont plutôt tendance à baser
leur compétition sur la force ou le
statut social en revanche elle a été
beaucoup moins étudiées en ce qui
concerne les femmes est donc une
première piste de logique de réponse à
notre question ça pourrait être tout
simplement celle ci la biologie et là
dessus il ya pas mal d'études
intéressante
je vais vous parler d'une étude en
particulier celles de deux chercheurs en
psychologie qui s'appelle james mcnulty
et john mann heures et eux ils ont fait
une étude qui démontre très clairement
que le taux de testostérone augmente
chez les femmes à qui on fait sentir à
un t-shirt d'une autre jeune femme en
période d'ovulation
elles sont pas au courant et du coup le
taux de testostérone et augmente et
résulte de sa une augmentation des
comportements de dominance et de
compétition il ya également une autre
étude qui pourrait être assez
intéressante c'est l'étude de deux
chercheuses cette fois ci en psychologie
ceux de l'orientation qui ont cherché à
comprendre comment est ce que les femmes
pouvaient se juger et se condamner en
fonction de leur apparence physique
ce qu'elles ont fait c'est que l on
demander à une assistante de recherche
de poser des questions aux groupes de
femmes qui étaient étudiés et à la fin
de l'enquêté une enquête qui avait rien
à voir avec le vrai sujet de l'étude
elles ont demandé à ces femmes là ce
qu'ils avaient pensé de l'assistante de
recherche
sauf que ce qu'elle savait pas c'est
qu'en vérité il y avait deux groupes
dans un cas l'assistante de recherche
avait été elle s'était présentée à elle
en étant extrêmement bien n'a prêté très
bien maquillée jolie coiffure de beaux
vêtements etc
alors que dans l'autre cas l'assistante
de recherche s'est présentée à elle en
n'étant pas spécialement mis en valeur
pas maquillée vêtements complètement
lambda et c est ce que le chercheuse au
crb c'est que les jeunes femmes avaient
critiqué majoritairement l'assistante de
recherche
quand elle était à son avantage alors
qu'au contraire elle l'avait carrément
ignoré quand elle était habillée et pas
forcément mis en valeur toutes ses
études et plein d'autres elles
soutiennent justement cette prédiction
évolutionniste
à savoir qu'une femme qui est considérée
comme attirante c'est-à-dire qu'ils
possèdent des attributs qui sont
valorisés par les hommes
eh ben elle recevra beaucoup plus
d'hostilité et beaucoup moins de
coopération de la part des autres femmes
qui craindraient finalement un petit peu
pour leur accès à un bon patrimoine
génétique
cependant ce serait par exemple une
erreur que de dire que la rivalité
féminine
elle s'explique que par la biologie ou
par l'évolution par exemple il ya plein
d'autres choses qui ont qui sont rentrés
en compte dans ce phénomène là et ce
serait une erreur que dire par exemple
les filles sont génétiquement programmé
à être jalouse les unes entre les autres
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont qui
sont rentrés en compte et notamment une
chose que je connais en particulier très
bien puisque c'est mon métier à savoir
l'histoire est là il ya énormément de
choses à dire parce que pendant des
centaines d'années pendant des
millénaires et dans de très très
nombreuses civilisations les femmes
dépendent entièrement des hommes pour
survivre dans le sens où que ce soit
pour sortir pour avoir un travail plus
tard pour avoir une carte bancaire par
exemple de l'antiquité jusqu'aux années
1950 à peu près en occident les femmes
ne disposait tout simplement pas de leur
propre droit est donc un des seuls
moyens à leur disposition pour acquérir
une place dans la société pour avoir un
statut social pour exister
eh bien c'était le seul marie et de se
marier de préférence avec un bon parti
pour s'assurer la villa moins pénible
possible
être choisie être au dessus des autres
femmes s'étaient donc au delà de tout
une nécessité
et à ce jeu là et bien très souvent les
filles les plus jolies d'un village par
exemple elle allait être un petit peu
avantagé avaient de meilleures chances
d'être bien marié et d'ailleurs les
petites filles elles étaient vus et
éduquée comme un placement
c'est à dire que un bon mariage c'est
garanti c'est grosso modo à toute la
famille une vie relativement pérenne et
forcément lorsque toute sa vie entière
dépend des hommes de son entourage et
pain et peut naître une forme de
rivalité entre les autres femmes et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que là où la
beauté chez l'homme
c'était un bonus une plus value mais
clairement il en dépendait pas pour
survivre
chez la femme c'est devenu quelque chose
d'extrême
important ça une nécessité à un moment
donné dans notre histoire et dans notre
évolution et c'est pour ça que la
rivalité féminine elle a été
particulièrement accentuée à cause de
notre histoire sur les notions de beauté
chez la femme
c'est pas parce que les filles sont plus
superficielle que les gars sont par
nature pas du tout c'est juste qu'on a
une évolution on a une histoire qui a
fait qu'à un moment donné on a eu beau
on a eu besoin de mettre en avant ses
qualités qui était valorisé par les
hommes et d'ailleurs on aurait toujours
un petit peu inconsciemment intériorisé
le besoin de plaire aux hommes et donc
par extension de se mettre en
compétition avec les autres femmes
tout ça c'est extrêmement intéressant
toutes ces études sont très pertinentes
puisqu'elle nous permettent de
comprendre un petit peu mieux pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en est là cependant réussir
à expliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya 300
ans on était en rivalité les unes avec
les autres
ça nous ça nous aide absolument pas à
comprendre pourquoi est ce que
aujourd'hui encore on ressent les effets
de cette rivalité a priori enfin on est
dans une société qui est moderne
les hommes et les femmes sont
relativement égaux en tout cas les
femmes ne dépendent pas des hommes pour
survivre donc on aurait a priori plus
aucun intérêt a évolué chimiste a
justement continué de ressentir cette
rivalité
donc ça répond pas à notre question
comment expliquer les faits instagram
là-dessus la réponse logique qui
pourrait nous venir comme ça ce serait
qu'on est toujours un intérêt évolutif à
ressentir cette rivalité mais est ce que
c'est vrai est ce que par exemple une
femme plus jolie aurait de meilleures
chances ou de meilleures possibilités
dans la vis plutôt étonnamment les
études en psychologie sociale tendent à
confirmer cette hypothèse
par exemple la notion de beauté on va
spontanément l'associer avec plein de
qualités qui n'ont absolument rien à
voir comme par exemple
l'intelligence la sympathie la
gentillesse ou encore la santé
être plus joli ça nous donnerait donc un
avantage en amour d'un point de vue de
reproduction certes mais pas que ça nous
donnerait également un avantage dans ce
marché du travail dans les études ou
encore hyper étonnant face à la justice
selon certaines enquêtes forcément
lorsqu'on baigne dans un dans une
société qui nous rappellent en
permanence que c'est quand même super
chouette d'être
joli eh ben on peut on peut justement
l'intérioriser par exemple si vous
regardez les médias la télévision le
cinéma les publicités tout notre
environnement
les marques cosmétiques qui s'adresse
principalement aux femmes tout notre
environnement est injecté de petites
suggestions qui sont faites aux femmes
en particulier sur leur intérêt d'être
plus joli et c'est pour ça en fait on a
on a on aurait finalement garder ce
prisme masculin comme étant le nôtre on
l'aurait acceptée on l'aurait conservé
dans notre société
selon cette idée une femme qui est née
et qui est élevé dans une société qui
reste malgré tout une société
patriarcale et bien elle intériorise ray
le regard masculin comme étant le sien
elle en reviendrait à faire des choses
justes pour correspondre à ceux à ce
regard là se conformer presque par
habitude et sans forcément le remettre
en question et d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
d'études dans le domaine des gender
studies
elles sont très nombreuses à mettre en
avant le fait que les femmes seraient
les premières responsables de la mise en
application de normes strictes et
parfois cruel en matière d'apparence
physique et de comportements sexuels
alors là les exemples ils sont multiples
on pourrait parler de de la façon qu'on
a les unes des autres de ceux lyncher en
fonction du nombre de partenaires
sexuels qu'on va avoir
dire que pour un mec c'est quand même
super chouette s'il a plein de
partenaires sexuels pour une fille c'est
un peu tabou mais on pourrait également
parler de pratiquer un petit peu plus
extrêmes comme par exemple le l'excision
la mutilation génitale féminine qui est
malheureusement encore toujours pratiqué
dans certaines parties du monde et ce
qui est intéressant avec ce concept là
en particulier c'est que cette pratique
elle a été créée donc de mutiler quand
même des enfants
elle a été créée uniquement pour
répondre aux besoins et aux attentes des
hommes
vraiment ça n'a aucune autre utilité que
celle ci est pourtant cette cérémonie de
l'excision
elle est mise en application gérer et
réalisé par d'autres femmes souvent ce
sera les grands mères ou alors les
mamans qui vont s'occuper de la
cérémonie dans un cas un petit peu moins
extrêmes on pourrait également parler de
l'épilation alors à main levée dans le
public qui s'est déjà écoulé au moins
une fois dans sa vie même un poil
vraiment tout compte
ok c'est un beaucoup de monde je vois
aussi
mais les garçons il ya dû avoir des
pères et des paris de père du hockey et
maintenant qui s'épilent plusieurs fois
par an la ccip rigolo parce que il ya
quasiment que des filles est maintenant
posez vous la question si on ne vous
avais jamais jamais jamais montrer une
seule image de femme épiler dans les
médias à la télévision c'est par exemple
toutes les femmes de votre entourage
avait toujours gardé leur poêle pendant
toute leur vie
est-ce que spontanément ce vous serez
venu en tête un matin comme ça elle vous
dira je m'arrache de l'épaule et vous
messieurs est ce que par exemple
spontanément vous auriez trouvé ça plus
esthétique une femme épiler qu'une femme
pas épilée en fait l'épilation c'est
devenu quelque chose de tellement normal
et banalisé dans notre société que c'est
presque devenu inhérents au genre
féminin
même quand on imagine une femme on
imagine épiler on ne peut pas imaginer
autre chose alors que quand on y
réfléchit
l'épilation c'est pas une pratique plus
extravagante que par exemple les pieds
bandés en chine ou encore les femmes
girafes en birmanie ou en thaïlande
en quoi s'arracher les poils du corps ce
serait une pratique en plus naturelle ou
plus féminine que d'autres modifications
corporelles
en fait c'est juste de prisme et ses
prises ils évoluent et changent en
fonction des civilisations et des
époques et ce qui est assez
contradictoire c'est quand même temps
ces prismes
ils deviennent de plus en plus difficile
de plus en plus inatteignable
parce que s'il ya 300 ans par exemple il
pouvait y avoir peut-être une ou deux
beautés vraiment extraordinaire au sein
d'un même village c'était de l'ordre de
l'exception aujourd'hui on ne vit plus
dans un petit village de seulement 200
ou 300 habitants vous côtoyez et vous
voyez au quotidien et dans au cours des
mois des milliers de visages et sur
internet
on est face à une nouvelle problématique
à savoir la sur-représentation
l'abondance l'amusante de la mise en
avant des beautés dit idéal ou
exceptionnelle avec en plus l'avènement
de photoshop de la chirurgie esthétique
et c est cette vision là qui est quand
même extrêmement biaisé elle nous ferait
presque oublier
que normalement ce genre de deux corps
sont très rares dans la nature ça ferait
presque passer l'exception pour la
normalité et l'anormalité enfin en tout
cas oui la normalité pour l'exception
c'est donc très complexes comme comme
mécanisme et du coup cette pression que
ressentiraient toutes les femmes ça
pourrait être également un autre une
autre réponse à notre problématique à
savoir les femmes en vivant dans une
société qu'ils qui les obligent plus ou
moins à intérioriser ces mécanismes l on
viendrait à semine auraient elles mêmes
par exemple à main levée d'un public
est-ce que vous avez déjà entendu parler
de parler du concept de fat talk
il ya personne jean littéralement
personne et pourtant c'est une pratique
enfin c'est un phénomène qui toucherait
plus de 86% des femmes selon les études
alors qu'est ce que c'est le fath talk
et bien le fath talk ce sont sous toutes
ses conversations que vous avez déjà
probablement une ou plusieurs femmes
vont se comparer les unes entre les
autres dans le but de se dévaloriser un
petit peu à qui sera la plus moche
typiquement ça va comme ça il ya une
amie qui arrivent et qui dit oh là là
t'as vu je me trouve vachement grosse
aujourd'hui et a vu mes cuisses ce à
quoi l'autre répond tu plaisantes
si toi tu es grosse alors moi je suis un
obus c'est risible dit comme ça mais
c'est un phénomène qui explicitent très
bien la frustration que peuvent
ressentir les femmes à accomplir
justement ces injonctions de beauté et
en même temps c'est assez paradoxal
parce que d'un côté la société nous
encourage partout dans notre quotidien à
être plus joli et de l'autre côté il
faudrait surtout pas dire qu'on se
trouve jolie parce que comme on l'a vu
les femmes ont tendance à rejeter celles
qu'elle considère comme un petit peu
plus séduisante de c'est vraiment une
technique évolutive instinctive on s'en
rend pas forcément compte donc une fille
qui se trouve plutôt bonasse et ben elle
n'a pas intérêt à dire à ses congénères
qu'être trouve cette qualité là chez
elle donc voilà on l'a vu on est quand
même toutes plus ou moins bercé dans
cette configuration et je pense que on
est un peu à des échelles différentes
tout malheureuse de ses injonctions
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de s'y
conformer alors est ce qu'il ya un moyen
éventuellement de s'en sortir
moi je me permettrai pas dans cette
conférence de vous faire un guide
complet sur comment sortir du patriarcat
en 12 étapes parce que déjà j'ai pas le
temps pas falloir que j'aille
après c'est surtout parce que c'est des
mécanismes qui sont extrêmement complexe
à la fois produit du présent et produit
du passé
on peut pas résoudre en une conférence
d'à peine dix minutes ce qui est le
résultat de millénaires d'un schéma qui
était plus ou moins imposée aux femmes
en revanche on peut peut-être tenté de
le faire changer
même s'il est extrêmement compliqué
d'être le premier à faire quelque chose
avant que la chose en question devienne
la norme
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe de
contagion sociale qu'est ce que c'est
c'est lorsque une idée va être partagée
au début par seulement une toute petite
poignée d'individus et voir vraiment
critiquée par la majorité mais qu'avec
une toute petite impulsion cette même
idée elle puisse justement devenir la
pensée majoritaire
pour vous expliquer sa g reprendre un
exemple qui m'a été inspirée de mehdi
moussaïd de l'excellente chaîne foule
scopique que je vous recommande
chaleureusement
c'est une vidéo en fait d'un festival où
comme on peut le voir au tout début et
bien il y a qu un seul mec qui danse
comme ça qui se trémoussent alors que
tout le monde est assis dans l'herbe
hors change tout le monde est assis dans
l'herbe à ce moment là il est donc un
petit peu ridicule et il ya certainement
des gens qui se moquent de lui mais
petit à petit il va être rejoint
d'abord tout doucement par une personne
et ensuite deux personnes et où est
comme ça à danser etc
jusqu'à ce qu'on atteigne ce qu'on
appelle la masse critique qu'est ce que
c'est c'est lorsque le nombre de
personnes devient suffisamment
conséquent pour augmenter
exponentiellement et donc la masse le
nombre de personnes il va augmenter
augmenté augmenter jusqu'à ce qu'on
atteigne le point d'inflexion c'est ce
point là ce moment où la norme n'est
plus de rester assise par terre
mais justement de danser et où les
personnes les rares personnes qui
restent encore assise par terre sont
considérées comme hors norme voire
ridicule
mon idée c'est que on pourrait utiliser
ce phénomène de contagion sociale
justement pour changer le schéma dans
lequel évoluent les femmes
mon idée c'est que en faisant beaucoup
plus preuve de sororité en montrant
beaucoup plus de représentation de
femmes avec qui gardent leurs poils ou
de femmes qui se montre torse nu et bien
peut-être qu'un jour on pourrait
atteindre ce fameux point d'inflexion où
la norme n'est plus de considérer les
poils féminin comme dégueulasse ou une
esthétique ou de considérer la poitrine
féminine comme est
immense sexuelle et où les femmes
pourraient choisir choisir de ses pieds
les ou non choisir de montrer sa
poitrine ou non tout comme les hommes
alors voilà il n'est jamais compliqué
d'être le premier danseur parce que
cette personne là elle sera
inévitablement confronté au rejet et au
ridicule et à la route mois avec vous ce
soir j'ai envie d'être la première
danseuse je suis challenge et et j'en ai
vraiment marre de toutes ces fonctions
qui sont faites aux femmes et de cette
rivalité ambiante qui en plus hyper
tabou dont personne ne parle vraiment
c'est quelque chose qui vraiment propre
à soi et j'ai envie de faire changer les
choses je suis challenge et je suis
persuadé qu une des seules façons en
tout cas une des meilleures façons qu'on
aime pour justement faire bouger un
petit peu les lignes c'est de briser
cette chaîne
je suis allongé et comme tout le monde
dans cette salle
j'ai des poils donc si vous souffrez de
ne pas être la plus belle et bien si
peut-être dès la première danseuse
[Applaudissements]